[Music]
foreign
what are your thoughts on where all this
will go I think there's just no doubt at
all the future is extremely bright we're
moving into this age where human
language will be able to be used as an
instruction language to tell your
computer what to do one way of to think
about the differences in comparison to
the kind of voice assistance or virtual
assistants that are available I think
all of us have had the experience that
those devices aren't always great if you
know the right way to word things
that'll do something but if you use the
wrong wording it won't the difference
with human beings is by and large you
don't have to think about that I think
that we'll start to see the same kind of
progression with these models that age
is opening up in front of us and that
will be hugely transformative